but you apparently you've also you've
learned skills in lockdown
yeah i learned how to write with my left
hand yeah
wow it's useful none of us thought of it
it sums it up doesn't it
20 20. yeah yeah that's like i don't
know because i do i write a to-do list
every morning
you know because it helps my brain
because my brain is quite i just thought
let me just like
i've always wanted to learn my left hand
so i just did it every day and what
happens is the first day
i did it i looked like i don't know i
looked like i was in
like a like my house is being bombed
that's how i looked
at my right my house was being bombed it
was shaking
i was running around but you seen the
progression in six months is amazing it
kind of makes you realize that yeah if
you just put your
put your mind to it and show up every
day like you can really make some
advancements yeah
that's really useful um and you can at
the same time
you do that at the same time adrian
you're giving me ideas
i'm thinking about that
yeah i want to see everyone's faces when
you do it when you go i'll make a note
of that
oh yeah yeah or in meetings i'll sign
all the checks
i'm signing all the checks
you